Rồi nhá. Câu hỏi của câu hỏi của bạn
Hiếu là thứ nhất có hai câu này. Câu đầu
tiên là cái time series nó khác gì với
linear reaction?
Về mặt bản chất hai cái này không so
sánh được với nhau. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
time series là bài toán còn linear
reaction nó là thuật toán. Hai cái nó
không so được với nhau. Bài toán giống
kiểu như này. Bài toán giống kiểu như là
giải đạo hàm, giải tích phân, giải lượng
giác. Đấy là bài toán.
Còn linear re thuật toán tức là cách để
chúng ta có thể giải được bài toán đó
không? Hai cái về mặt bản chất nó không
hai cái về mặt bản chất nó nó nó
không tương đương nhau. Không tương
đương nhau. Thế nhưng mà anh hiểu cái ý
của em hỏi em ý em là từ đầu đến giờ
mình học linear reaction bây giờ mình
học này nó khác gì nhau đúng không? Em
tưởng tượng nhá. Ví dụ như là linear
reaction mình sẽ một cái mô hình dữ án
giá nhà đi đúng không? Thì có phải input
đầu vào sẽ là gì? Input đầu vào nó sẽ là
diện tích căn nhà, số tầng căn nhà, vị
trí căn nhà, có sổ đỏ hay không, có vi
bằng hay không, vân vân vân. đúng không?
Và sa cái output đồ ra là cái giá của
căn nhà đó. Đấy là cái bài toán linear
reaction chúng ta hay quen nó đúng
không? Thế còn đây nó khác cái bài toán
nó khác là gì? Tôi sử dụng nó để tôi dự
án nó. Tức là gì? Tôi sử dụng cái nhiệt
độ ngoài trời của những hôm vừa rồi để
tôi dán nhiệt độ ngoài trời hôm tiếp
theo. Đúng không? Tôi dựa vào doanh số
doanh thu của những hồ rồi, tôi sẽ đán
doanh số doanh thu hôm tiếp theo. Tức là
cái thứ đầu vào và đầu ra nó là cùng một
thứ, chẳng qua nó ở nhiều thời điểm khác
nhau thôi. Thế còn bình thường cái
linear reaction mà chúng ta hay làm ấy
là input đồ vào và output đồ ra là những
thứ khác nhau đúng không? Tôi dựa vào
những cái ông này tôi dựa vào ông kia.
Được chưa? Đấy là cái sự khác biệt. Thế
nhưng mà mình vẫn có thể dùng linear
reaction để mình ốp vào bài toán time
series được. Tại vì về mặt bản chất hai
cái nó không tương đương nhau. Một cái
là thuật toán, một cái là bài toán. Được
chưa? Cái thứ hai nếu dự đoán theo kiểu
direct recourit có dự đoán liên tiếp
được cả hai cách tiếp cận hôm qua đều dự
đoán liên tiếp nhận ra chị trong tương
lai được thoải mái chả vấn đề gì cả đấy
đúng không qua các bạn nhìn vào cái hình
đây
cả hai cái hình mà các bạn nhìn thấy hôm
qua nó đều minh họa cái cái điều đấy mà
đây
đây đúng không đầu tiên nhá
Recurip trước nhá. Đúng không? Recurive
thì hiển nhiên đúng không? Hiển nhiên nó
dự án được đây. T + 1, t + 2, t + 3 thì
có phải là các cái giá trị liên tiếp
trong tương lai đúng không? Tiếp này.
Direct m xem không? Direct m step đây. T
+ 1, t + 2, t + 3 nó cũng là các giá trị
tương lai liên tiếp nhau mà đúng không?
Hai ông ông nào chả được đúng không? Các
muốn các bạn muốn dự đoán bao nhiêu giá
trị trong tương lai mà chả được đúng
không? Liên tiếp nhau nhảy cách quãng
nhau kiểu gì cũng chơi được chưa?
Ok. Trước khi vào thực hành có câu hỏi
gì không?
Thế nhá. Thế bây giờ hôm qua chúng ta
học về cách bài toán nó chỉ có như vậy
thôi đúng không? Bài toán nó chỉ có như
vậy thôi. Nó khác với cái bộ diabet. Bộ
Diabt là cái bộ ví dụ là là cái bộ
student score là cái bộ mà các bạn chỉ
dự đoán tại một thời điểm thôi. Còn đây
là các bạn có thể dự đoán nhiều thời
điểm trong tương lai đúng không? Bản
chất của cái bài toán này là cái input
và cái output thật ra là về cùng một đối
tượng chẳng qua là cái đứa tới ở nhiều
thời điểm khác nhau thôi. Được chưa? Thì
bây giờ chúng ta nói về cái bộ dữ liệu.
Bộ dữ liệu thì ra mình up trên mình up
trên Google Drive rồi nhưng mà mình sẽ
gửi lại đây cho các bạn. Các bạn đỡ phải
ngồi các bạn tìm nhá. Cái bộ rượu nó là
bộ về lượng ký thải CO2
đây nhá. Cái bộ ký đây nó bộ CO2 này.
Đây mình gửi trên trên Zalo thì các bạn
đỡ phải các bạn đỡ phải đi mò trên
Google Drive nhá. Được chưa các bạn? Chờ
tí nó mình đang gửi này.
Được chưa? Cái bộ ví dụ là cái bộ về
lược khí thải CO2. Cái bộ này trông như
thế này. Những bộ này nó trông như này.
Ở trong này nh cái những cái script hôm
qua mình up cho các bạn rồi nhá. Những
cái script về bài toán NLP mình up rồi
này. Về cái bài toán à về computer
vision cũng up rồi đúng không? Chúng nên
chúng sang bài toán mới là nên
bài toán mới chúng ta sẽ làm cái script
mới. Một cái script mới nhá.
Mình nghĩ là
series
này nhá. Ch casting nhá. Được chưa? Thế
bây giờ mình vẫn phải đọc rượu vào thôi
đúng không? Mình tắt những cái khác đi
nhá. Bây giờ mình
import pandas spd này. Được chưa? File
là file file là file CSV thì mình cứ đọc
bình thường thôi. Nó sẽ file đây được
chưa? File CSV đọc bình thường thôi.
Được chưa? Lấy ra và phần các bạn chú ý
là thông thường ấy
à
thông thường các cái các bạn mà đọc
những cái tutorial ấy người ta thường
người ta sẽ khi người ta đọc các cái
file bằng Pandas ấy người ta sẽ không
lưu tên là data đâu. Ngườ ta sẽ hay ghi
là DS này hoặc là data frame đây nhá.
Data frame thì data frame nó là cái gì?
Data frame là nó là cái định dạng dữ độ
dạng bảng của riêng Pandas. Trên Pandas
thì người ta gọi những cái dạng bảng tức
là mảng hai chiều nó là gọi là data
frame. Còn nếu mà là cột hoặc là mảng
một chiều người ta gọi là series. Đấy
người ta thông thường nên là các bạn ấy
cái tài liệu người ta hay ghi là data
frame hoặc viết tắt là DF này chứ ít khi
người ta viết là data. Thế nhưng mà về
mặt bản chất nó là dữ liệu thôi nên là ở
đây mình viết cách này nhìn cho nó dễ.
Được chưa? Người ta như này tức là các
bạn có thể các bạn mở ra đây bối đen ra
này đúng không? Click chuột phải này
đúng không? Chọn execute selection in
Python console này. Chọn vào đây nhá.
Được chưa?
Xong thì các bạn chờ một tí dưới góc góc
dưới bên phải nó lại hiện ra cái bộ rượu
thôi. Mình sẽ ngồi xem nó xem trong mặt
mũi như thế nào. Được chưa? Bộ này tên đ
ngắn thôi.
Đây là cái bộ liên quan đến lượng khí
thải CO2.
Nó chỉ nhìn qua chỉ có hai cột đúng
không?
Nhìn qua nó chỉ có hai cột là cột thời
gian và cột CO2. Ừ trong lúc chờ nó hiện
nhá.
Cái cột thời gian các bạn thấy không?
nói thì người ta sẽ ghi này
nó chỉ có hai cái cột này thôi đúng
không? Cột thời gian thì
cột thời gian thì các bạn nh các cái giá
trị nó cách nhau cứ một tuần một tuần
một tuần đúng không? Cứ một tuần một
tuần một tuần thế này được chưa? 29
tháng 3 năm 1958, 45 tháng 4 năm 1958,
12 tháng 4 năm 1958 vân vân. Được chưa?
Đây cũng chả biết nó là lượng khí thải
hay là cái gì mà mình đoán là thế thì
cột tên là CO2 chả biết là khu vực nào
cũng chả biết đơn vị nó là cái gì mà chỉ
biết nó là có một cái giá nó có những
cái giá trị dạng số đúng không? Nhìn qua
cái bộ rượu này có một cái điểm nó sẽ
đập thay vào mắt chúng ta đó là cái gì
các bạn? Nhìn qua vào cái bộ rượu này có
ngay một thứ nó đập vào mắt chúng ta đó
là
đó là
à có những ô nó bị khuyết đúng không? Nó
có missing value, nó có nan đúng không?
Nan hoặc là missing value. Đúng rồi. Có
dượu bị khuyết. Thống kê thử đi. Thống
kê thử đi. Đúng không? Ngồi đếm thì ấy
lắm phải thống kê đúng không? Thống kê.
Thống kê thử nhá.
Green data.info
ta ch info nhá.
Nhìn qua đây
có tổng cộng là 2284 hàng. Được chưa?
Cham thì đầy đầy đầy đủ còn CO2 nó bị
khuyết. Nó bị khuyết khuyết mất khoảng
ô nó bị khuyết đi.
Thế
à? Ok. Dượ biết là Diệu bị khuyết rồi.
Bây giờ bây giờ chúng ta hãy thử trực
văn hóa đi. Trực văn hóa đi. Những cái
bài trước ví dụ như như cái bộ diabet
thì không có gì trực văn hóa tại vì mỗi
một hàng nó chả liên quan đến nhau. Mỗi
một hàng là một bệnh nhân chả liên quan
gì đến nhau. Hoặc là cái bộ student
score thì mỗi một hàng là một học sinh
nó cũng chả liên quan gì đến nhau. Nhưng
mà cái bộ này mỗi một hàng nó là cùng về
thông tin của một thứ nhưng mà nó tại
những thời điểm khác nhau. Nên làm gì
làm. Chúng ta hãy hãy thử nghĩ đến việc
là chúng ta sẽ sẽ trực văn hóa nó xem nó
trông nó như thế nào. Đúng không? Thực
văn hóa này ra thí hình.
Thế thì với cái a với cái với cái dữ
liệu kiểu như này chúng ta sẽ chúng ta
sẽ dùng chúng ta sẽ dùng chúng ta sẽ
dùng thư viện chúng ta dùng mapp được
chưa? Có cái hôm chúng ta học về lý
thuyết chúng ta học về mapp rồi hôm nay
chúng ta sẽ thực hành luôn được chưa?
form maplip
trong map public nó có một cái package
con tên là pipel plot này người ta rất
hay dùng đây cái package để phục vụ cho
việc vẽ vời các thứ là người ta hay
import này một là như này hai người ta
import kiểu như này này import
chesspt
thật ra bây giờ các bạn cũng không phải
để ý lắm tại vì sau này các bạn cũng vi
code cả thôi thế nhưng mà đấy nó có hai
kiểu import như thế được chưa đấy import
xong mình sẽ phải vẽ nó thì các bạn có
nhớ là cái hôm chúng ta học về chết rồi
cái slide mình xóa chứ rồi à đóng rồi
nhá nhá. Cái hôm chúng ta học về cái vẽ
đây, mình dùng tạm slide cũ bản cũ này.
Hôm chúng ta nói về cái vẽ, các bạn có
nhớ là mình có nói với các bạn là gì? Đó
là đôi khi các bạn sẽ không dùng được
những cái kiểu các bạn sẽ không dùng
được cái hàm một phát xong luôn này mà
các bạn sẽ phải à vẽ nó nhiều hơn một
chút. Thế thì các bạn có nhớ là cái hôm
chúng ta học về MIP ấy, mình có nói với
các bạn là gì? Là trong MP ấy người ta
quy định được cái gì? Là muốn vẽ cái gì
thì vẽ. Các bạn sẽ phải có một cái khung
lớn là một cái figer. Trong cái khung
lớn này các bạn sẽ có những cái khung
con. Mỗi khung con này người ta gọi nó
là một cái access đúng không? Figer là
cái khung lớn nó giống như ở kiểu cái
bàn ăn ấy đúng không? Còn cái assess là
nh những cái khung con các bạn có thể
một có nhiều asset. Ví dụ đây các bạn
thấy các bạn có các bạn có đây các bạn
có chín cái access này. Được chưa? Mỗi
một khung con này giống như kiểu một cái
đĩa đựng thức ăn đúng không? Thì đĩa
phải đặt trên bàn rồi đô ăn là phải đặt
vào đĩa đúng không? Thế tức là sau này
các bạn vẽ vời gì là các bạn sẽ vẽ vào
cái đĩa và cái asset ấy. Được chưa?
Thông thường cái trường hợp cơ bản là
các bạn sẽ chỉ có một access, một
figure, tức là một khung lớn, một khung
con thôi. Được chưa? Ví dụ trong trường
hợp này chúng ta cũng chỉ muốn vẽ như
vậy thôi đúng không? Chúng ta chỉ có một
khung lớn không con thôi, chúng ta không
phải vẽ ra nhiều thứ. Được chưa? Bây giờ
trong map public ấ muốn khởi tạo không
thì rất là dễ thôi. Khung lớn không ngon
bạn khởi tạo rất là dễ. Các bạn sẽ có
một cái dòng đó là pick này.
Addest này. Các bạn sẽ có một cái dòng
này. Cái dòng này là dùng để tạo ra
khung lớn và khung con. Mặc định ấy nếu
các bạn cứ dùng mặc định nó sẽ tạo ra
đúng một khung lớn, một khung con. Còn
các bạn muốn tạo ra nhiều hơn thì nó sẽ
có những cái tham số ở trong. Nhưng mà
thôi tạm thời các bạn chưa cần phải đi
quá sâu vào cái đấy. Được chưa?
Có một cái điểm các bạn nhìn này. Cái ý
tưởng là vẽ cái gì? Bây giờ có vẻ là
mình chỉ có hai giá trị thôi đúng không?
Mình có giá trị là thời gian và giá trị
là cái lượng khí thải CO2 đúng không?
Thì bây giờ cái ý tưởng của mình là mình
gì? Mình sẽ vẽ nó trên một cái hệ trục
tọa độ DC là hệ tọa độ OXY ấy, đúng
không? Oxi thế chính hội Oxi này thì
trục hoành mình sẽ để phải là thời gian
trục tung là CO2 đúng không? Để các bạn
xem là cái lượng khí thải CO2 nó thay
đổi nó nó như thế nào. Được chưa? Trục
tung thì không vấn đề gì. Trục tung thì
nó là dạng float rồi. Float 64 tức là
dạng số nó là dạng double rồi. Nó là số
thực rồi không có vấn đề gì. Nhưng trục
hoành trục hoành ấy chúng ta là con
người. Chúng ta nhìn vào chúng ta biết
nó là giá trị thời gian. Thế nhưng mà ấy
muốn ngôn ngữ lập trình nó hiểu ấy thì
chúng ta sẽ phải xử lý một chút. Hiện
nay cái cột thời gian này nó là cái dạng
object. Object có nghĩa là gì? Các bạn
hiểu là trong trong Python ấy nếu mà
chúng ta không quy ra nó kiểu gì nó sẽ
là kiểu object. object nó là tất cả
những cái kiểu bao giờ chữ này text này
rồi những cái kiểu gì mà không format
được thì người ta đưa vào d object thì
bây giờ ấy muốn mà vẽ được trong hệ trục
tọa độ ấy mà cái trục hoành nó biểu tộ
nó biểu thị yếu tố về mặt thời gian ấy
thì chúng ta sẽ phải convert cái kiểu
của nó đi. Tức là gì? Cái giá trị nó
hiện ra thì vẫn như thế này nhưng mình
phải convert nó sang cái dạng người ta
gọi là dạng de time. De là cái dạng về
về thời gian. Thế thì trong PAS á,
Pandas nó có một cái hàm gọi là de time
này. Th time tức là chúng ta không
convert giá trị nhưng chúng ta convert
cái kiểu của nó. Giống kiểu là cùng là
số 5 nhưng mà nó có thể là số thực, nó
có thể là số nguyên, nó có thể là string
đúng không? Kiểu kiểu như vậy. Thế thì
nó sẽ đây nó chỉ convert kiểu thôi còn
giá trị nó y chang nó không khác gì cả.
Thế thì khi mà các bạn muốn dùng cái này
ấy thì ờ để ý một chút tức là về mặt cái
giá trị kiểu ngày tháng năm ấy, cái kiểu
ngày tháng năm như này nó thường nó sẽ
có hai kiểu. Một là kiểu ngày tháng năm
viết xuôi,
ngày bao nhiêu, tháng bao nhiêu, năm bao
nhiêu là viết xuôi. Hai là kiểu 5 tháng
ngày là viết ngược. Năm bao nhiêu, tháng
bao nhiêu ngày bao nhiêu. Đây này, cái
kiểu viết ngược này. Được chưa? Đấy. Thì
các bạn muốn convert các bạn phải chỉ ra
là gì? Là cái kiểu rượu tôi ấy nó theo
kiểu gì? nó theo kiểu ngày tháng năm hay
là năm tháng ngày. Được chưa? Đấy. Thì
bây giờ muốn chỉ ra các bạn nhìn này.
Trong cái trong cái hàm to time này ấy
nó có một cái tham số nó ghi là nó có
hai tham số chính xác hơn là day first
với cả year first. Thông thường ấy các
bạn chỉ cần chỉ ra một cái thôi. Day
first thì khỏi year first mà year first
thì khỏi day first. Nó giống cái gì các
bạn nhỉ? Nó giống cái hàm gì nhỉ? Có hai
cái nó các bạn chỉ một cái thôi. Day
first với year first này nó giống cái gì
các bạn?
Nó giống cái hàm gì ấy nhỉ? Đúng rồi.
Chên split đấy. Đúng không? Trên split
đâ. Các bạn chỉ ra cái bộ tren các bạn
khỏi chỉ ra bộ test. Test khỏi bộ trên
không cái cái cái tỉ lệ giữa hai bộ đấy
đúng không? Cái của mình là year first.
Cái của mình là year first. Được chưa?
Nếu mà các bạn không chỉ ra cái gì cả
thì mặc định nó sẽ là year first. Được
chưa? Như mà thôi mình cứ mình cứ tường
minh thôi. Một là các bạn ghi year first
bằng true, hai các bạn ghi là day first
bằng. Thế nào cũng được. Một trong hai
cái đúng không? Bây gi mình mình sẽ dùng
thử nhá. Mình dùng to này. Được chưa?
Đấy thì bây giờ tôi có dữ liệu tôi ở đây
đây kéo xuống dưới này. Được chưa? Trước
đấy trước khi mà tôi vẽ vời thì tôi sẽ
convert tí đi đúng không? Lượng
time được chưa? Bằng
này to de time như này được chưa? Tôi sẽ
phải chỉ ra là year first year first
bằng true này đúng không? Tại vì đúng là
đúng là mình là năm đi đầu mà đây này.
Năm đi đầu mà đúng không? Năm đi trước
đúng không? Ngày tháng năm ngày tháng nó
đi sau. Đấy. Thế thì sau khi mình xong
rồi thì mình sẽ mình chạy lại thử nhá.
Mình print này data.info nhá. Info này
nhá. Để cho xem là lúc trước nó là
object đúng không? Object float 64 nhá.
Bây giờ các bạn nhìn này. Cái ông object
nó sẽ không còn là object nữa. Nó sẽ
chuyển thành cái dạng gọi là time đây
này. Des này. Được chưa? S thì như này
rồi. Thì bây giờ mình mới có thể mình vẽ
lên cái chị trục tọa độ nó mới hiểu được
là đây là về mặt thời gian. Được chưa?
Nó giống như kiểu là nó giống như kiểu
là bây giờ các bạn ghi này thì ai cũng
hiểu là số 5 nhưng máy nó sẽ không hiểu
đây là số, nó sẽ hiểu đây là đây là chữ
là ký tự đúng không? Thì các bạn phải
convert nó thành kiểu in. Đấy kiểu kiểu
như vậy đây nó y chang như thế được
chưa? Đây là mình tạo ra cái biểu đồ
này. Tạo ra cái biểu à mình tạo ra cái
khung lớn là cái figure và access là cái
khung con. Được chưa? Thế sau đó thì
mình sẽ làm mình phải vẽ. Thế bây giờ
cái kiểu vẽ của người ta cái kiểu vẽ dễ
nhất là gì? Là bây giờ như này,
kiểu vẽ dễ nhất ấy là bây giờ mình sẽ vẽ
lên hệ trụ tọa độ như này. Mình sẽ vẽ
từng điểm một. Mình sẽ vẽ từng điểm một
như này. Đây nhá. Chủ độ như này đúng
không? Đấy.
Hoành là thời gian, tung là CO2 đúng
không? Thì có vẻ bây giờ các bạn muốn vẽ
các bạn sẽ phải chỉ ra từng điểm. Một
điểm này, hai điểm này, ba điểm này, bốn
điểm này, năm điểm vân vân. Xong người
ta sẽ nối các điểm vào nhau đây. Nối từ
đầu vào đây. Đấy, nối cái này đúng không
Cứ hai ông liên tiếp nối vào nhau. Đấy,
cái kiểu như vậy thì nhiệm vụ của chúng
ta chỉ là chỉ ra cái bộ điểm này thôi.
Ví dụ chúng ta chỉ ra 100 điểm đúng
không? Chỉ ra 100 điểm sau đó nó sẽ nối
với nhau. Thế thì chỉ ra 100 điểm này ấy
thì map nó sẽ quyết là gì? Là các bạn sẽ
chỉ ra 100 cái hoành độ trước và 100 cái
tung độ sau. Chú ý nhá, số lượng hoành
độ phải bằng tung độ. Tại vì sao? Tại vì
mỗi điểm bao gồm luôn bao gồm một hoành
một tung mà đúng không? Các bạn phải chỉ
ra là số hoành bây giờ số điểm hành với
số điểm tung đúng không? Thế bây giờ các
bạn sẽ có một cái hàm. Các bạn sẽ có một
cái hàm thôi. Nhớ là gì? có một cái
khung lớn và cái khung con. Khung con
thì đặt vào trong khung lớn và vẽ gì thì
là vẽ vào khung con đúng không? Nên là
vẽ gì dùng cái cái asset này tôi dùng
cái hàm hàm plot được chưa? Hàm plot này
các bạn nhìn này, các bạn sẽ chỉ ra là x
trước, x là thời gian còn y là CO2 đúng
không? X đi trước, Y đi sau. Được chưa?
Chỉ như thế này thôi. Nhớ là hai ông này
nó phải cùng kích thước 100 phần tử thì
cùng 100 phần tử. Được chưa? Lot như
vậy. Sau đó các bạn có thể thêm cái các
bạn có thêm cái label tức là cái tên cho
trục hoành với trục tung nữa. Ví dụ là
các bạn sẽ có một cái hàm là set x label
như này được chưa? X label mình ghi là
time đúng không? X Y label ghi là CO2
được chưa? Mình sẽ show ra show ra các
bạn nhìn nhá. Mình sẽ không in này nữa.
Nó chỉ mỗi ngày thôi. Được chưa? Mình
tạo ra khung lớn khung con này. Trên
khung con các bạn vẽ ra mình có bao
nhiêu đi nhỉ? Mình có hai khoảng 200
đúng không? Nó cứ vẽ ra đúng không? Ông
nào bị khuyết thì nó là nan thôi. Được
chưa? Nó vẽ ra vẽ ra đây. Được chưa? H
với cả CO2. Bây gi mình sẽ vẽ nhá. Mình
sẽ vẽ nhá. Mình show ra này. Trước khi
chạy các bạn thử dự đoán xem theo các
bạn khi mà mình visualiz này lên theo
các bạn là cái xu hướng lượng khí thải
CO2 theo các bạn nó sẽ thay đổi như nào?
Theo các bạn cái xu hướng lượng khí thải
CO2 này nó sẽ thay đổi như nào các bạn?
Tăng. Ừ có thể nó sẽ tăng đúng không?
Chạy thử nhá. Chạy thử nhá. Chạy thử
nhá. Dự đoán nó tăng đúng không? Chạy
thử này.
Đây nó như này.
Như thế này. Được chưa? Đúng là tăng
đúng không? Tăng nhưng mà không phải là
tăng dần lên mà nó sẽ tăng kiểu zí rắc
rắc rắc đúng không? Có một số khu vực
như chúng ta vừa chúng nói là như này
đây ví dụ đây đúng không? Có những cái
ông nó bị nan như này. Nan như này. Tất
nhiên vẫn như mọi bài dữ liệu nan không
thể có thể để đấy được phải xử lý đúng
không? Xử lý. Chúng ta có khoảng 2200
hàng và chúng ta có khoảng năm mươi mấy
hàng 59 hàng nó đang bị nan đúng không?
Theo các bạn những cái ô bị nan này
chúng ta phải xử lý nào bây giờ? Những ô
bị nan này xử lý nào bây giờ?
Những ô bị nan xử lý nhưế nào bây giờ?
Các bạn xử lý kiểu gì?
Giống cũng được. Mình đang chỉ các bạn
cách cách khác đấy. Không các bạn dùng
profile cũng được. Nhưng mà các bạn chú
ý là khi mà các bạn dùng cái profile
report ấ nó sẽ không tạo ra cái đường
như này đâu. Các bạn có nhớ cái profile
report ấy à nó cũng có một cái đúng rồi.
Cái profile report nó cũng có một cái
biểu đồ là chị có học hai ông nhưng mà
các bạn muốn dùng profile các bạn phải
convert được cái cái trục thời gian đã.
Không thì đưa vào nó cũng không hiểu
đâu.
Dùng nãy được mà đúng không? Tại vì prof
nó hơi nhiều hơn so mấy thứ mình cần
đúng không? Đây mình chỉ cần mỗi cái đồ
thị thôi mà.
Nào các bạn những cái ô bị khuyết chúng
ta làm thế nào? Ừ
đầu tiên các bạn cho mình hỏi nhá. Đầu
tiên cho mình hỏi này. Cái cách mà mọi
người thường hay nghĩ đến là cách chúng
ta sẽ drop, chúng ta sẽ bỏ đúng không?
Hàng nào mà bị khuyết thì bỏ cái hàng
này đi. Sao ở đây chúng ta lại sao nãy
giờ từ nãy giờ không có bạn nào đề cập
đến cái việc là bỏ hàng. Còn 59 hàng nó
bị khuyết ch gì tôi bỏ đi. Bỏ đi có được
không?
Mình bỏ được không?
Giả sử không phải 59, giả sử chỉ là 19
thôi. Giả sử chỉ là 19 hàng bị khuyết
thôi. Bỏ 19 hàng này đi được không?
Giả sử chỉ có 19 thôi. 19 là ít mà.
À đúng rồi. Bình thường với các cái bộ
như là bộ diabet hoặc là bộ score ấy các
bạn bỏ thoải mái chả vấn đề gì. Tại vì
sao? Tại vì mỗi hàng nó độc lập với
nhau. Hàng này nó chả liên quan gì đến
hàng kia. Các bạn bỏ thoải mái chả có
vấn đề gì cả. Nhưng cái bộ này các bạn
không không làm như thế được. Các bạn bỏ
là các bạn sẽ mất tính ng mất cái tính
liền mạch đúng không? Ví dụ các bạn muốn
sử dụng cái mô hình làm sao dựa vào cái
lượng khí thải CO2 của 5 tuần để dựa vào
những tuần tiếp theo chẳng hạn đúng
không? Thì các bạn phải có cái sự li chứ
đúng không? Vậy các bạn bỏ đi thì lấy
cái gì thì nó mất cái sự liên tục đi rồi
đúng không? Hàng nó đang liên tục như
vậy các bạn bỏ đi nó mất rồi đúng không?
Nên là với bài toán time series cái việc
bỏ dữ liệu nó sẽ không dễ như là bài
toán khác. Bài toán truyền thống bình
thường là mỗi ông là một hàng thì bỏ
thoải mái. Bỏ ông này nó chả ảnh hưởng
gì ông kia. Nhưng cái này không không bỏ
như thế được. Được chưa?
Rồi. Thế thì vậy các bạn bảo là lấy
trung bình cái này. Lấy trung bình lấy
trung bình ông trước ông sau thôi. Nhưng
mà khả có khả năng cao là sẽ ông trước
ông sau cũng bị khuyết luôn. Tức là có
những chỗ nó khuyết là nó khuyết cả cụm
luôn. Nó khuyết khoảng 5 s tuần liền
luôn. Nên là lấy trung bình ông ông
trước ông sau cũng chưa hẳn là là xử lý
được. Được chưa?
Mình lấy trung bình trên toàn tập được
không các bạn? Mình lấy trung bình trên
toàn cái tập này mình điền vào có được
không? Mình lấy trung bình tất cả các
cái giá trị từ năm 58 đến năm 20 bộ này
là đến năm bao nhiêu nhở? Đến năm 2001
thì phải.
Đây mình lấy trung bình của tất cả 2000
mấy giá trị này mình cộng trung bình lại
được không?
Sao lại không được?
Sao lại không được? Sao lấy trung bình
không được? Mọi khi chúng ta vẫn hay lấy
trung bình mà.
Trung bình hoặc là trung vị đi. Trung
bình hoặc là trung vị có được không các
bạn?
Mọi khi người ta vẫn hay là làm thế mà.
À đúng rồi, lấy trung bình cái này cũng
không được vì với cái bộ này đúng không
nó cứ nằm ở giữa mãi không ổn. Đúng rồi,
nó không ổn. Chỗ này t vào đây không ổn
đúng không? Với có một bạn mà nói là
dùng interpolation. Interpolation đấy là
cái chúng ta cần làm. Interpolation
tiếng Việt là gì các bạn? Interpolation
tiếng Việt là gì?
Nội suy. Đúng rồi. Thế nào là nội suy?
Trong toán học thế nào là nội suy? Nội
suy là chúng ta dùng các cái điểm xung
quanh để dán điểm ở giữa đúng không? Còn
ngoại ngược lại là ngoại suy là
extrapolation là gì? Là dựa vào cái điểm
ở giữa để dán điểm xung quanh đúng
không? Đúng rồi. Đây mình dùng nội suy
được chưa? Dùng cái điểm xung quanh để
dán điểm ở giữa. Nội suy dùng cực kỳ dễ.
Với PANAS thì mọi thứ cực kỳ dễ luôn các
bạn nhìn nhá. Nội suy đúng không? Mình
nội suy thì mình sẽ có một trong Pandas
nó có một cái hàm nó tên là nó tên là nó
tên là interpolate cho các bạn xem thử
nhá. Đây interpolate là như này này. Dây
ra nhá.
À CO CO2 nhá đúng không? Bằng data này
CO2 này chấm này interpolate này được
chưa? Interpolate là nội suy được chưa?
Nội suy thế thôi chạy thử này chạy thử
này. Lúc trước thì như này nhá đúng
không? Chỗ thở ra chỗ hở ra chỗ thụt vào
nhá. Được chưa? Bị mất khuyết chỗ này
chưa? Bây gi mình thử nội suy chạy nhá.
Các bạn nhìn này. Nội suy này.
Đẹp chưa?
Nhìn đẹp nhìn đẹp chưa?
Tất nhiên thật ra nếu mà nhìn mà kiểu kỹ
tính hơn một chút thì các bạn thấy là
cũng có những chỗ chỗ nội suy nhìn nó ra
ngay đúng không? Nên cái chỗ tự nó lại
mượt bất ngờ thế này nhìn nó ra ngay.
Nhưng mà anyway nó cũng nó cũng phản ánh
được tương đối cái xu hướng đúng không?
Phản ánh tương đối cái xu hướng của
chúng ta thấy chưa? Cũng có thể coi chấp
nhận được chưa? Nhân về CO2 đ cho điền
điền vào đúng cho chư quân hóa rồi. Được
chưa? Rồi các bạn bây giờ các bạn đọc dữ
liệu rồi xử lý cái ô bị khuyết rồi trực
văn hóa rồi bước tiếp theo chúng ta làm
gì? Ví dụ đi mục tiêu của mình là mình
sử dụng một cái mô hình để làm sao dựa
vào lượng khí thải CO2 của năm tuần liên
tiếp để dự đoán những cái tuần tiếp theo
đúng không? Dự đán tuần thứ sáu thứ 7 8
thứ 9 ví dụ như vậy được chưa? Mục tiêu
là như thế. Và cách tiếp cận của mình là
mình dùng cách tiếp cận đầu tiên đi là
kiểu recursif. Recurive là tôi chỉ dùng
một mô hình thôi.
Đây recitive và tôi chỉ dùng đúng một mô
hình thôi. Tôi dự ấn n giá trị trong
tương lai tôi cũng chỉ dùng đúng một mô
hình thôi. Được chưa? Thế b theo các bạn
bây giờ
đây. Rồi bước tiếp theo mình sẽ làm cái
gì bây giờ?
T mình sẽ làm cái gì bây giờ?
Chưa chưa á? Chưa. Chưa.
Các bạn nhìn nhá. Cái rượu này
à đúng rồi các bạn chú ý này. Cái rượu
này tuy nó là dạng bảng rồi nhưng cái
bảng này các bạn không nhét được ngay
vào mô hình đâu đúng không? Như hôm qua
chúng ta học rồi đúng không? Nó đúng là
nó là sao nó dượ bảng nhưng mà bảng này
không nhét ngay vào mô hình được phải
convert đã. Các bạn nhớ hôm qua chúng ta
học đây này. Bước này này đây này. Đấy
phải biến nó thành rượu mà phải biến
thành rượu mà truyền thống bình thường
ấy. Mình mới chia chia gì chia sau đâu.
Chia xy rồi chia x/ test chia sau đúng
không? Đấy thì bây giờ thật ra chúng ta
học xong thực hành rồi mình sẽ chỉ bạn
một cái thư viện. Một cái thư viện mà
các bạn sau này các bạn chuyển đây này
cái thư viện mình chỉ bạn này. Cái gì
nhỉ?
Quên sử tên rồi. SK
for Cast đây. Sau chúng cái thư viện
này. Đây là thư viện nó sau này các bạn
chỉ cần đưa rượu gốc vào nó tự làm hết
cho các bạn một phát là xong. Đây một
phát là xong các bạn đưa rượu vào nó tự
làm hết mọi thứ cho các bạn. Thế nhưng
mà nếu mà dùng cái này luôn ấ các bạn sẽ
không hiểu bản chất từng bước nó làm cái
gì. Thế nên là chúng ta vẫn làm cái bước
thủ công trước xong thì anh chị bạn dùng
thư viện này rất là dễ luôn nhá. Thư bện
này các bạn dùng chỉ 10 dòng xong xong
bài.
Thế thì bây giờ chúng ta sẽ phải biến
diệu thằng kiểu như này đúng không? Biến
kể rượu này nó sẽ có
nó sẽ có hai cách. Một là như này. Ví dụ
bạn hành cột như này nhá. Đúng không?
Cột như này. Đấy
được chưa?
Đấy như này đúng không? 1 2 vân vân
xuống dưới này được không? Cách đầu tiên
là gì? Là các bạn đấy các bạn dùng cái
windows như này một cái window như này.
Đấy các bạn cứ lấy ra lấy ra 6 ô đúng
không? Mỗi lần lấy lấy 6 ô 5 ô là x 1 ô
là y. Sau các bạn cứ dịch dịch cứ dịch
một đơn vị một đơn vị một đơn vị giống
kiểu như này này. Làm kiểu như này. Cái
này người ta gọi là sliding window cửa
sổ trượt. Cái kể cửa sổ trượt này nó đơn
giản đơn giản dễ thực hiện. Các bạn làm
cái vòng lọc loop hoặc là một cái vò vọp
for trong python là xong rồi. For i cái
gì đấy được chưa? Nhưng cái này có một
cái nhược điểm.
Các bạn cho mình hỏi làm theo kiểu
sliding window này nhược điểm là gì các
bạn?
Cách này nhược điểm là gì? Các các bạn
đang nhìn cái animation này nhược điểm
là gì?
Nhược điểm là gì các bạn?
Nhược điểm của cái này là gì?
Không.
Dữ liệu sai thì là sai của dữ liệu,
không phải sai do mình đâu. Mình nói cái
sai cái nhược điểm của cái slide Windows
này cơ chứ còn dữ liệu sai là lỗi của nó
chứ không phải cái kỹ thuật này đâu.
Chạy lâu đúng chạy lâu. Vì sao lâu? Vì
sao lâu?
Câu này bạn nào mà học môn cấu trúc dữ
liệu và giải thật rồi các bạn phải trả
lời được câu này. Bạn nào học môn cấu
trúc dữ liệu và giải thật rồi các bạn
phải trả lời được câu này. No không phải
99% nó không không liên quan.
Bạn nào không phải dân IT thôi nhưng bạn
nào là dân IT đã từ học cấu trúc dựa bài
thật thì các bạn phải trả lời được câu
này. Vì sao cái này nó lại chậm à đúng
rồi đúng ph tập là ON đúng không? Big O
đúng không? Với N là số lượng phần tử
đúng không?
Đúng không? Độ phức tạp của toán nó to
là do vòng lặp đúng không? Người ta
thường người ta lập trình ta hạn chế
vòng lặp đúng không? Thì bây giờ nếu
không là cái này ấ có một cách khác có
một cách khác. Các bạn nhìn cách khác
này
bây giờ nhá mình không làm như này. Mình
xem kiểu khác kiểu khác là gì? Bây giờ
vẫn cái vẫn cái đống này. Vẫn cái đống
này đây.
Từ mình xóa này đi. Được chưa? Vẫn cái
đống này nhá. Bây giờ mình sẽ
Đấy. Mỗi lần các bạn nhìn thấy tức là
gì? Mình sẽ nhân bản nó và mỗi lần mình
sẽ dịch luô một tí.
Đấy như thế này. Nhân bản nó rồi mỗi lần
tôi dịch đi một tí. Được chưa? Sau phải
có một cái nữa của đúng không? Thì bây
giờ tôi lấy tôi sẽ lấy theo tôi lấy theo
đây này.
Tôi lấy theo kiểu này này. Đấy.
Tôi lấy nguyên theo một hàng thế này
đúng không? Thằng nào t thay vì tôi phải
dịch nhiều lần tôi chỉ là tôi tạo nhân
bản hóa lên tôi lấy ra đ ông dịch 1 dịch
2 dịch 3 dịch 4 thì 5 dịch 6 này sao
đúng không? Mà cái này thì không cần
phải vòng lặp nữa đúng không? Làm thế
này hoàn toàn không cần vòng lặp. Nếu có
lặp các bạn chỉ có lặp là các bạn lặp để
các bạn tạo ra năm cái ô này thôi. Tạo
ra thêm bốn cái phiên bản nữa thôi.
Nhưng mà thế độ phết tập là O1 thay vì
ON đúng không? O1
được chưa? Thế mình làm cái này nó sẽ
nhanh hơn. Dùng Slang Windows thì cũng
được nhưng mà nó mất thời gian ra được
chưa? Ờ ờ cái gì ấy nhở?
Rồi ok đúng không? Thế mình sẽ thử làm
cách này nhá. Tức là mình sẽ cứ shift 1
shift 1 shift 1 để xem là đúng không nó
sẽ đỡ cái việc tránh cái vòng lặp đúng
không các bạn? Trong lập trình người ta
tránh vòng lặp tại vì là vòng lặp nó là
cái thứ nó khiến cho độ phức tạp nó tăng
lên. Được chưa? Thế bây giờ mình sẽ có
thể là bây già
đi. Tạ một cái hàm đi. Đó de này được
chưa? Recurive
create đi.
Create này. Recurive
data nhá. Được chưa? Qu recursive data
này. Mình sẽ input đồ vào là cái data
của mình thôi. Data này được chưa? Mình
sẽ phải truyền ra mình phải chỉ ra cái
cái cái window size của mình là bao
nhiêu? Windows
size ví dụ bằng 5 đi. Tức là input vào
tôi có năm feature đúng không? Tí nữa ở
dưới mình sẽ mình sẽ định nghĩa ở dưới
sau. Mình cứ định nghĩa này đã được
chưa? Tức là gì? Tôi muốn là tạo ra một
cái bộ dữ liệu tôi sẽ có năm input đầu
vào và một cái output đầu ra đúng không?
Trong năm input đầu vào thì sẽ có sẵn
cái cột đầu tiên là cột gốc rồi mình
phải tạo ra thêm năm cột nữa. Đấy chưa?
Đấy. Thế bây giờ mình muốn tạo ra thêm
thì mình sẽ có thể làm một cái vòng lặp
y chẳng hạn đúng không? Các bạn có một
cái biến y này. Y = 0 chưa? y
nhỏ hơn Windows size này. Được chưa? Tôi
sẽ tôi sẽ tạo ra những cột mới. Cái cột
cũ tôi tô sẽ gọi là CO2 CO21, CO22 vân
vân các thứ này format này. I được chưa?
Bằng cái gì? Bằng data
CO2 này. Trong panas nó có một cái hàm
gọi là hàm shift hàm shift như này.
Nhưng mà các bạn shift các bạn không
shift theo theo số dương. Tại vì số
dương nó sẽ shift theo ngược cái hướng
các bạn muốn. Các bạn phải đi theo chiều
âm. Ch âm ra trừ y này. Shift trừ y này
th cho các bạn y cộng bằng 1 đây này.
Được chưa? Đấy các bạn phải các bạn phải
shift theo thật ra đây mình không có
mình hướng dẫn các bạn shift cộng các
bạn để ra số cộng tuy nhiên các bạn nhìn
thấy nó bị ngược ngay mà chưa sin -1 tí
mình sẽ d chứ v hóa lên các bạn nhìn xem
là như nào nhá. Xong đấy ở ngoài mình sẽ
return thôi. Đây này return data nhá.
Được chưa? Thế có phải là bây giờ ở dưới
này mình sẽ không chế quân hóa nữa. Được
chưa? Chỗ này xong rồi đúng không? Xong
rồi. Được chưa? Bây giờ mình sẽ convert
nhá. data bằng create recip data này
đúng không? Windows size mình cho bằng 5
đi được chưa? Hoặc mình cho mình cho một
cái tham số ở đây Windows size bằng 5
thôi. Được chưa? Windows size đây
như này nhá. Chạy thử này. Được chưa?
Chạy thử này. Xem nhá. Từ cái cột gốc
ban đầu n tạo ra những cột mới nhá. Nhìn
này.
Đây data như này các bạn thấy chưa? Lúc
ban đầu nó chỉ có trang với cả CO2 thôi.
Bây giờ nó thêm là CO
chạy từ 1 ch nhở. Sao nó chạy từ 0 à?
Chạy chạy từ 1 đi đúng không? Tại vì có
sẵn một cột rồi đúng không? Chạy từ 1 đi
đây đúng không? Cham này t mình cũng bỏ
đi thôi tại vì nó chỉ dùng để mình tạo
dữ liệu thôi mà. Đ tí nữa mình bỏ rồi.
CO2 này, CO21, CO2, CO23, CO24. Được
chưa? Đây chính là năm cái feature đồ
vào đấy đúng không? Đấy các bạn âm dịch
một ô này đúng không? Có phải đây không?
316,1 nhá. 37,3 đúng không? Có phải nó
lên đây đúng không? Đ chéo lên này. Đấy.
Đây là các bạn shift shift theo chiều âm
đấy. Nó mới lên như này. Shift theo
chiều dương lại đi hơ ngược lại. Được
chưa? 3 17,6 này. 37,6 này. Được chưa?
317,5 này. Được chưa? 316,4 này. Được
chưa? Đấy, nó dịch theo hướng mà mình
cần này. Được chưa? Mình còn thiếu cái
gì các bạn nhở? Thiếu cái gì nữa? Thiếu
cái gì nữa? Thiếu cái gì? Thiếu cái gì
nhỉ?
Muốn dựa vào lượng giải CO2 của năm tuần
rồi, án tuần thứ sáu chẳng hạn. Mình
thiếu cái gì đây? Thiếu của Tit đúng
rồi. Thiếu Tit Tit thì lại dịch tiếp
thêm nữa thôi đúng không? Tit cho dịch
ra ngoài nữa này. Đúng không? Tit đây.
Được chưa? Đây ta này. Đúng không? Tit
này
đúng không? Thì bằng đây trừ
đúng rồi. Trừ trừ trừ trừ y thôi. Trừ
tiếp cái y này đúng Windows size cũng
được là tại vì ra đây là y nó bằng
Windows size rồi các bạn. Cho trừ
Windows si cũng được là trừ y cũng ok
cả. Được chưa? Chạy thử nhá. Thử nhá.
Đấy được chưa? CO2 CO21 CO22 CO3 CO4 là
Tit được chưa? Tí như này đấy đúng
không? Tí nó được tít từ này mà lên này.
Này 316,9 này. Từ đây mà ra này. Thấy
chưa? Đấy
đến đây rồi. Nhưng mà các bạn nhìn này.
Nhìn này. Kẹp xuống dưới nhá. Kẹp xuống
dưới này các bạn nhìn này. Ở cuối có mấy
ô bị nan này. Có mấy hàng bị nan đâu. Có
năm hàng nó chứa những ô nan. Hàng thì
chiếu một giá trị, hàng chiếu nhiều. Tôi
làm gì với mấy cái hàng bị nan này bây
giờ?
Tôi làm gì với mấy cái hàng bị nan này
bây giờ?
Bị nam tôi làm gì bây giờ?
Việt Nam tôi làm gì?
Làm gì bây giờ?
Bỏ sao sao sao sao lúc đầu nó có nan mà
các bạn không bỏ? Bây giờ có nan các bạn
lại bỏ. Sao vừa nãy có nang các bạn
không bỏ, bây giờ có nang các bạn lại
bỏ. Cùng là cái rượu này sao vừa nãy
không bỏ bây giờ lại lại bỏ được?
Vì sao vừa nãy các bạn nhất quyết các
bạn không bỏ? Bây giờ các bạn lại bỏ.
Ừ cũng là một ý. Đúng cũng là một ý đúng
không? Không không có target thì làm sao
đúng không? Ông nào thì còn cố điền được
chứ còn tit làm sao mà cố điền được đúng
không? Đấy là một lý do. Và lý do nữa là
gì? Là mấy ông này nó liền nhau và nó ở
cuối rồi đúng không? Tôi chỉ sợ là bỏ
những ông nó ở giữa giữa giữa chứ nó
liền nhau nó nó ở cuối thì tôi bỏ đi là
xong đúng không? Vậy bỏ thì tôi sẽ lại
dùng hàm drop thôi. Đây
ta bằng data chrop nan này đúng không?
Assist bằng 0 là theo hàng bằng 1 là
theo cột đúng không? Asis bằng 0 được
chưa? 0 là hàng một là cột à. Ờ ừ đúng
rồi. Chạy thử nhá. Chạy thử lại này.
Chạy thử nhá.
Đấy được chưa? Đẹp rồi. Được chưa? Đẹp
rồi.
Rồi
rồi. Có data rồi. Theo đúng format
format rồi. Bước tiếp theo mình làm cái
gì các bạn? Bước tiếp theo ngay sau cái
dòng số 22. Dòng 23 mình làm cái gì đây?
Mình làm cái gì ở dòng 23 đây?
Dòng 23 làm gì đây?
Dòng 23 làm gì bây giờ?
Chuyên test speed ờ chưa chưa trước trên
speed phải làm một cái nữa là gì? Giống
giống mọi bài thôi là gì?
Là mình phải tách ra x với y đã đúng
không? Ch spit là các bạn phải có xy làm
gì đã có gì đâu đúng không? XY đã.
X thì dễ thôi đúng không? X thì dễ thôi
không không vẫn chạy bình thường. Vẫn
chạy bình thường yên tâm. Vẫn chạy bình
thường nhá. Yên tâm
nhá. Các bạn nhìn nhá. Bây giờ xy thì
rất là dễ thôi. Bây giờ x thì tôi lấy
năm cái cột này. CO2 đến CO24. Còn Tit
là lấy của Y đúng không? Time thì bỏ đi.
Time luôn nó chỉ dùng để tôi đối chiếu
thời gian thôi. Xong rồi tôi bỏ đi. Được
chưa? Cái kiểu này kiểu giờ phút giây
ngày tháng 5 này. Được chưa? Ngày tháng
5 thì mình không có giờ phút giây thì
mình nó là không hết. Được chưa?
Thế bây giờ lấy ra nhá. Thì bây giờ x
này đúng không? X này bằng data đúng
không? Chấm drop ch drop đúng không? Mọi
khi chúng ta vẫn dùng này. Ta drop mọi
khi là mình chỉ drop mỗi cột target
thôi. Còn bây giờ mình phải drop nhiều
hơn mình phải drop cái cột time nữa.
Ờ time được chưa? Drop hai cột. Còn y
mình chỉ lấy đúng một tí thôi. Chạy thử
nhá.
Đây x đây. Được chưa? Còn đúng năm cột
được chưa? Y đây đúng một cột. Đẹp chưa
nhá. Rồi bây giờ thì mới tách. Đây là
tách theo chiều dọc đúng không? X sang
một bên, Y sang một bên. Tiếp theo tách
theo chiều ngang.
Mọi khi tách theo chiều ngang mình sẽ
dùng chet split đúng không? Tất cả các
bài trước giờ chúng ta đều trung thành
với chet split.
Nhưng bài này mà dùng chet split nó sẽ
có cái không ổn. Bài này nếu dùng chet
split nó sẽ có cái nó không ổn. Bạn nào
chế mình câu một ở đây là gì?
Bạn nào chí mình cái không ổn đây là gì
các bạn?
Ở đây mà dùng ch split về mặt kỹ thuật
thì vẫn chạy được nhưng mà người ta sẽ
không làm thế. Với bài toán time series
người ta sẽ không dùng ch split. Lý do
là vì sao? À đúng rồi nó có thứ tự đúng
không? Suy cho cùng nó vẫn là thứ tự.
Bây giờ các bạn cứ tưởng tượng là bây
giờ
liệu trông như thế này. Dượ trông như
thế này nhá.
Nhọ trông như thế này đúng không? Bây
giờ nó đang nó liên tục này bây giờ bên
bên tách nó nó lộn xộn bộ chuyên bé thì
thì thì nó đâu có sự liên tục nữa đúng
không? Nó không có tức là ấy tức là khi
mà người ta chia bộ dữ liệu dành cho bài
toán time series ấy người ta sẽ muốn
phân chia gì? Tức là cái bộ chuyên nó
phải liên tục nhau để nó học cái sự liên
tục. Bộ test phải cũng phải liên tục
nhau. Đúng chưa?
Thế v các bạn tưởng tượng này, bây giờ
muốn liên tục ấ nó sẽ có hai kiểu. Một
là bộ test sẽ là cái bộ ví dụ là chia tỉ
lệ 80 20 đi thì bộ test một sẽ là cái bộ
cũ nhất tức là nó sẽ là 20% xưa nhất,
hai nó sẽ là 20% mới nhất. Theo các bạn
bộ test nên là bộ nào? Bộ test nên là
20% cũ nhất. Tức là từ những năm 6 năm
58 60 đấy. Hay nó nên là 20% mới nhất.
Theo các bạn
nó nên là bộ nào?
Đúng rồi, test nên là mới nhất đúng
không? Test nên là mới nhất đúng không?
Bao giờ chúng ta sẽ ưu tiên bộ test là
bộ mới được chưa? Tại vì bây giờ mình
mình mà huấn luyện mô hình xong mình
test cái cũ quá nó cũng chẳng có tác
dụng gì cả. Bây giờ tôi đang cần dùng
tôi dự đoán những cái năm tiếp theo. Bây
giờ tôi dùng từ tôi test về những năm
mấy thì nó có tác dụng gì đâu. Đúng
không? Test nên là mới nhất.
Được chưa? Giống kiểu các bạn đi ôn thi
để thế thôi có các bạn sẽ luôn ự các bạn
ôn thi các bạn sẽ luôn học với bộ cũ các
bạn thi với bộ mới chứ làm gì có ai
ngược lại đâu đúng không? Đấy thì bây
giờ mình tách mình sẽ không dùng trên
split nữa mình chỉ tách thủ công mình
dùng sliding của 5 number thôi đúng
không? Tách hoàn toàn thủ công luôn như
thể là chưa có thư viện đúng không? Tách
này đúng không? Mình sẽ có một cái là ờ
gì nhở train size đi bằng 0,8 đi. Được
chưa? Mình sẽ có một cái là nonum
temple bằng lens của bộ train X train
này. Được chưa? L của X cũng được. Là
của X nó làm gì nó có xin đâu đúng
không? Thì bây giờ mình sẽ chia kiểu gì?
Mình sẽ là
mình viết liền thấy nhỉ? Ừ ờ
tách nó ra chưa nhỉ?
Được chưa? Xrain nhá. Xe này bằng cái
gì? Bằng X này đúng không? Mình dùng
sliding như này.
Xchain Ye phải có cái in này. Tại vì nó
slide nó phải số nguyên phải phẩy phẩ
phẩy nó không lấy được. Số thực nó không
lấy được đúng không? Số nguyên này. Xin
Ye đúng không? Thì bây giờ X test này.
Test bằng X này. Đây mình lại Yest đây.
Test này. Được chưa? Đấy.
Chạy thử nhá.
Thử này
đấy các bạn thấy đúng không? Đây nhá. Có
phải là exchange là 1423 đúng không? X
test có 456 thôi đấy đúng không?
Y
gì này sa lệch này x
trên y/ên x test
x
y trên à đúng rồi đúng rồi đúng rồi các
bạn đúng rồi rồi
yest trên đúng rồi được chưa phân chia
rồi
Nào các bạn bây giờ
đúng không? Phân chia theo chiều dọc
rồi, theo chiều ngang rồi. Thế làm gì
tiếp bây giờ? Làm gì tiếp đây?
Làm gì tiếp bây giờ?
Là nên làm cái gì đây?
Chuẩn hóa dữ liệu. Chuẩn hóa thì làm nà
làm thế nào bây giờ? Chuyển hóa dữ liệu
chuẩn hóa như thế nào bây giờ?
Chỗ nó làm nào bây giờ?
À đúng rồi, không cần đúng không? Đúng
rồi, không cần bài này thì lại không cần
chuẩn đoán dữ liệu. Vì
vì sao mình lại không cần chuẩn đán dữ
liệu các bạn?
Vì sao lại không cần?
Tại vì chúng nó làm sao?
Vì sao mình lại không cần chuẩn hóa nhỉ?
Không phải là chỉ có CO2 mà lý do là do
chúng nó từ một gốc mà ra đúng không?
Chúng nó từ một gốc năm cột thật thật ra
là từ một gốc mà ra đúng không? Chúng nó
cùng một scale. Cùng một scare cùng một
cái giải chia rồi không cần thiết. Các
bạn scare thì các bạn scaling thì cũng
được thôi nhưng mà nó không cần thiết
đúng không? Không cần thiết.
Rồi nhá. Cái bước này comment đi cho rõ
bung ra nhá. Rồi thế thì bây giờ nếu mà
không phải tiền xử lý thì bây giờ mình
làm cái gì tiếp các bạn? Không tiền xử
lý thì tôi làm cái gì bây giờ?
Thì tôi làm gì?
Chọn model. Ừ. Theo các bạn bài này nên
chọn model như thế nào? Theo các bạn nên
chọn model như thế nào?
Ơ bạn Hiếu với có phải học lớp Disneying
cơ bản không nhỉ? Sao nhìn thấy tên quen
quen nhỉ?
Có phải Hiếu với học lớp Disney cơ bản
không nhỉ? N mình nhớ nhầm nhỉ?
Mô hình à không phải đ nh quen quen nào
các bạn ờ theo các bạn bài nên nên chọn
mô hình như nào theo các bạn linear
direction à
các bạn khác thì sao?
Có một cái thứ chúng ta chưa làm có một
thứ chúng ta chưa làm gì thì chúng ta
chưa tính ra ma trận hệ số tương quan
đúng không? Chúng ta chưa tính ra ma
trận hệ số tương quan
nhá.
mà chạy số th quan các bạn phải bỏ cái
cột thời gian đi đúng không? Drop
chúng ta chưa in ra. Theo các bạn cái
mặt trận hệ số tương quan này lúc mình
in ra nó lại trông như nào các bạn? Theo
các bạn cái ma trận hệ số tương quan này
mình mới in ra trông nó như nào đây? Cái
dòng này dòng số 27 này là in ra ma trận
hệ số tương quan này. Correlation đấy.
Theo các bạn lúc mình in ra trông lại
như nào?
Trông như nào?
Theo các bạn
dự đoán xem trông như nào?
Không ai dự án được à?
Ma trận hệ số tương quan mình mà chạy
trông như thế nào?
không ai dự án được à.
Vừa nãy các bạn vừa bảo là chúng ta
không cần phải tiền xử lý. Tại vì sao?
Tạiì nó chung một gốc mà ra đúng không?
Với các bạn bảo là chúng ta không phải
xử lý mấy cột CO2, CO21, CO2, CO3, 24
các thứ tại vì nó chung một gốc
không? Mình bỏ cột thời gian rồi còn đâu
bỏ rồi còn gì nữa đâu.
Các bạn bảo là các cái rượu tao nó từ
cùng một gốc đúng không? CO2 CO21 CO22
CO3 4 CO21 235 các thứ bây giờ cái cột
tit nó từ cùng một gốc mà ra mà vì nó
cùng từ một gốc nên là theo các bạn cái
chế số tương quan trông lại như nào?
Vì các bạn bảo các cái cột cùng từ một
gốc mà ra không phải bằng 1
làm sao bằng 1 được. bằng 1 là chỉ có
chính nó thôi. Chỉ có hệ số tương qua
của một ông với chính nó thì mới bằng 1
thôi. Còn không nó không thể nó bằng 1
được.
Nào tất cả các cột từ một gốc và ra thì
hệ số tương quan trông lại như nào? Ồ
hay
đây
nó làm sao?
Ơ các bạn cái đức thống kê cơ bản vào ơ
nó lớn đúng không?
Lớn không?
Nay cộ tit này th có lớn không đúng
không? Bởi vì nó lớn như vậy lúc mình
chọn mô hình mình chọn mô hình như nào
các bạn?
Lúc chọn hình tôi chọn m hình như nào?
Đúng rồi. Mình tuyến tính thôi đúng
không? Về cứ tuyến tính thì cứ linear
regression và phang thôi đúng không?
Nghĩ nhiều làm gì đúng không? Form hay
kit learn chấm đây đúng không? Nó chỉ
ngay linear reaction này bạn thấy chưa
nhá. Thôi cho này print khỏi phải print
nữa được chưa?
Model
model bằng linear được chưa? Do fit và
trên này đấy mình lại là lại predict này
đúng không? Pix này chưa? Mình lại in ra
mấy mấy cái magic cơ bản thôi. Đây bài
trước code rồi bài này lấy ra lại thôi.
Được chưa? Đây có mấy cái magic này đúng
không? Còn đây min mủng các thứ đây.
Được chưa? Đấy đâu nhỉ?
Đây
được chưa? Dưới nhá.
Đây một cái magic này.
Đấy chưa?
Minus min square coefficient of
determination nhá.
Đây kết quả đây
các bạn nhận xét nào.
Có ai có comment gì không?
Ai có comment gì không?
Comment gì không các bạn?
Ngôi chúng ta như nào?
Không có comment
ừ này. Ừ tốt đúng không? Ừ 99% này đúng
không? Tốt đúng không? Tốt. Rồi riêng
với bài toán time series ấ các bạn nhớ
là chúng ta bài toán time series nó có
một cái ưu điểm là gì? Là các bạn có cái
đoạn chư cân hóa rất là mạnh. các cái
bài toán khác ấy thì mỗi một sample nó
về một ông chả liên quan đến nhau thì
người ta ít trực quan hóa th bài toán
chực quán hóa cực mạnh luôn. Thì bây giờ
mình sẽ muốn trực quân hóa cái kết quả
này đúng không? Biết nó tốt rồi. Chự văn
hóa. Chự vân hóa bây giờ mình sẽ có ý
tưởng là mình sẽ muốn vẽ ba đường. Thứ
nhất là đường của bộ train. Thứ hai là
đường của bộ test và thứ ba là cái
prediction của bộ test. Được chưa? Thì
bây giờ mình sẽ lấy từ trên thôi. Từ
trên này này. Đấy nhưng mà bây giờ mình
sẽ vẽ nó phải khác đi một tí. Khác đi
một tí. Mình B chỗ B B chỗ trên nhá. B
xuống dưới này. Được chưa? bên xuống
dưới này. Thế bây giờ
mình cùng này nhá. Được chưa? Thế bây
giờ lúc trước mình chỉ vẽ một đường nó
dễ. Bây giờ mình sẽ phải vẽ ba đường
khác nhau. Thứ nhất là đường của bộ
trên. Đường của bộ trên tôi sẽ không lấy
hết này mà tôi chỉ lấy đúng cái đối đạo
của bộ trên thôi. Đây bộ trên là cái chỗ
này này. Được chưa? Tôi đế đúng cái
sling này thôi đúng không? Tôi lấy đúng
của bộ trên nhá. 1 này. Được chưa? Đường
của bộ trên đây là x của bộ trên này.
Đây sẽ là y của bộ tren này. Được chưa?
Các bạn vẽ một đường thì không sao. Các
bạn vẽ nhiều đường ấy thì các bạn nên
thêm cái label cái nhãn để biết nó là
cái gì. Sau này nó sẽ hữu ích. Label ví
dụ ghi là trên nhá. Một đường này được
chưa? X với Y nhá. Mình tắt Y cho nhìn
nó rộng nhá. Được X với Y nhá. Được
chưa?
Tiếp này. Cái đường thứ hai là của bộ
test. Bộ test thì nó chỉ có đổi cái dấu
này xuống cuối thôi. Được chưa? Test
đây.
Test đây. Được chưa? Bộ này mình sẽ ghi
là bộ test.
Còn cái cuối cùng là của prediction.
Prediction thì X nó giống ờ X nó giống
nhau chỉ khác nhau mỗi Y thôi. Y này sẽ
không còn phải là cái chỗ à thật ra cái
chỗ này mình ghi đây cũng hơi thừa. Tức
là các bạn có thể ghi là đây là
E train đúng không? Đây là E test và đây
là E predict thì đúng hơn đúng không?
Đúng hơn I này. Được chưa? Đấy input
input đầu vào là cái gì? Output đầu ra
là cái gì? Kiểu kiểu như thế được chưa?
Trên test vậ đây là prediction này.
Prediction này được chưa? Trước mình chỉ
vẽ một đường thì các bạn không cần cái
label. Một đường thì dễ rồi nhưng mà có
nhiều đường thì các bạn phải có cái
label ấy thì tí nữa mình mới tí nữa có
cái label ấy thì mình mới mới
mình mới có cái chú thích này được đúng
không? Phải có label tí mới có chú
thích. Có nhiều đường thì nên có chú
thích nhìn cho nó tường minh. Được chưa?
Xong thế thôi. Vẫn thế nó chạy thử nhá.
Chạy thử này.
Chạy thử nhá
các bạn nhìn nhá.
Tôi có ba đường. Cái đường bộ trên đây.
Đ bộ test về prediction thì nó hơi bị
díu với nhau. Đây này. Trên này đúng
không? Nó hơi bị díu với nhau đúng
không? Tất nhiên là khi mà có nhiều hơn
một đường chúng ta nên có cái chúng ta
nên có cái chú thích đúng không? Hôm nọ
chúng ta học chúng ta có hai cái gì?
Chúng ta có cái thứ nhất là cái legend
là cái chú thích và cái win để các bạn
dóng cho nó dễ đúng không? Bây gi mình
có thể mình úp cả hai vào này. Legend có
chú thích nhá. Được chưa? Còn cái win
kia là nó sẽ có cái bảng bảng chia. Các
bạn nhìn đây nhá. Legend rất là dễ. Ax
này chấm legend. Xong. Còn green thì
chấm green. Đây. Legend thì là legend.
Green thì là green thôi. Green là cái
lưới chia. Legend là cái bảng trúng
thích. Được chưa? Thử này.
Đấy.
Được chưa?
Tất nhiên tại vì là mô hình nó dự án tốt
nên các bạn thấy ham này nó khít vào
nhau như này. Được chưa? Mô hình dự án
cao là phải thôi. Tại vì các cái feature
có hệ số tương quan lớn với tít đúng
không? Hệ số tương quan rất là lớn. Anh
nói như này. Được chưa?
Rồi các bạn đến nay có ai có câu hỏi gì
không? đến bước này có em có hỏi gì
không?
Không mai có câu hỏi gì thì bây giờ
chúng ta thử nhá. Chúng ta thử này.
Đây là
đây là đây đây là với mô hình linear
reaction nó rất là tốt đúng không? Thì
như chúng ta dự đoán ban đầu đúng không?
Tại vì là hệ số tương quan lớn mà. Bây
giờ mình muốn đổi ra một cái mô hình
khác. Ví dụ bây gi mô hình nữ mình dùng
random forest đi đúng không?
Tất nhiên là với bài toán này khả năng
cao là mô hình phi tuyến nó sẽ không tốt
bằng nhưng mà mình muốn xem là nó tốt
đến mức nào.
Chấm unple này
re nhá. Được chưa?
Được chưa? Mình có cái random state
random
state này
xem ví dụ như vậy đi.
Cái này nó ổn định quá có với các kiểu
rượu khác nhau. Ví dụ trong cái bài này
thì với các cái rượu khác nó còn có cả
rượu ngoại lai nữa. Tức là đây mình chỉ
có thuần cái CO2 thôi. Trong chúng ta có
ba cái bộ rượu. Chúng ta có ba cái bộ
rượu
nữa về cái bài toán time forcasting mình
up cho các bạn lên cái trên Google Drive
ấy. Đấy ba cái bồi này nó sẽ có cả thêm
rượu khác nữa. Thì lúc ấy khi các bạn có
thêm rượu ngoài các bạn sẽ phải xử lý
thêm vào. Xử lý thêm giống như những cái
bài trước thôi. Được chưa? Đây là trường
hợp đơn giản là các bạn chỉ có mỗi CO2
thì nó dễ. Các bạn chỉ có mỗi một kiểu
cho nó dễ đúng không? Còn khi mà dữ liệu
nó biến động ấy thì các bạn hiểu là dù
nó biến động ấy thì khi mình tạo ra
nhiều cột thì tất cả cột này cùng biến
động như nhau mà đúng không? Tôi tạo ra
một bốn cột từ một cột góc ban đầu thì
tất cả chúng đều biến động như nhau mà.
Chứ có phải là một ông biến động mấy ông
kia bình ổn đâu đúng không?
Nhìn nhá. Với random fres nhá. Tôi để
random fred này các bạn nhìn này.
Các bạn nhìn này.
Random kết quả như này. Các bạn thấy nó
như nào các bạn?
Fạ các bạn thấy nào?
Fres các bạn thấy thế nào?
Các bạn thấy nó làm sao?
Không ai thấy làm sao?
rất là tổi đúng không? Không bằng không
ổn. Chúng ta là nó rất là tổi ừ đúng
không? Đến gần đến gần 360 nó đi ngang.
Được chưa?
Các bạn nhìn này. Ví dụ đi lần trước với
cái hôm chúng ta làm cái bộ student
score ấy đúng không? Các bạn thấy là ví
dụ cái bộ với cái bộ student score đi có
thể là với mô hình linear reaction đi nó
tốt nhất. Tại vì là chúng ta có cái điểm
đọc với cái điểm viết nó có hệ số tương
quan lớn với cả điểm toán đúng không?
Thì ví dụ là cái điểm của cái mô hình
linear direction nó là 10 điểm đi thì
Rom Fred nó cũng phải được 8 9 điểm. Tức
là ok R Fred nó không tốt bằng nhưng mà
nó tức là nó tồi hơn một chút đúng
không? Nhưng mà các bạn nhìn thấy cái
bài này lại khác hẳn tức là gì? Linear
reaction rất là tốt đúng không? A square
gần gần một luôn gần 100% trong khi cái
mô hình random for này nó lại rất là
tổi.
Ai lý giải để cho mình vì sao lại như
vậy? Rõ ràng hôm nọ chúng ta làm cái bộ
serent score đúng không? Hai mô hình coi
như là 19 110 mà đây hai mô hình nó khác
hoàn toàn nhau mà ô 10 â 1 ai sẽ cho
mình là vì sao với cái bài lần trước thì
không thì trên lệch d hình nó không có
nó nó không có lớn đến mức như này nó
không có lớn thì kiểu mẫm rất tốt móm
rất tồi thế này đúng không đây trường
hợp này lại khác linear cực kỳ tốt trong
khi phép lại cực kỳ tồi ai thấy được vì
sao cái sự khác biệt giữa hai bài nó lại
lớn như vậy
vì sao các bạn
vì sao vì sao vì sao
Thử nghĩ xem vì sao lại như vậy?
Vì sao đúng không? Rõ ràng hôm nọ cái
hôm chúng ta làm cái bộ điểm của học
sinh ấy đúng không? Linear reation tốt
hơn một phép một chút xíu thôi không
đáng kể đúng không? Coi như cũng có tốt
hơn nhưng mà cái bài lại khác hoàn toàn
nó móm rất tốt móm rất tồi đầu bài lần
trước thì cũng cũng random không bài
trước cũng cái random set mà random
random fred thì
bản thân nó là tên nó là như thế đúng
không tên nó là như thế đúng không hôm
nọ thì cũng là đầm fred chứ không phải
mô hình gì khác đâu đúng không hôm nọ
cũng là mô hình đấy mà
đúng không hôm nọ với cái bộ season cũng
là cũng là random khác gì đâu
không phải bú Bot shopping. Bot shopping
thì hôm nọ cũng thế mà hôm nọ chả khác
gì đây. Hôm nọ y chang yì đúc luôn. Hôm
nọ với cái bộ điểm của học sinh này y
chang mình không làm một cái gì khác cả
chưa? Chả làm cái gì khác cả. Trang đúng
không? Khác thì cái đầm xếp mà ta đây có
fit vào cũng thế thôi. Đây 1009 nhá. Đây
nm
fr nó chỉ trả ra cái kết quả trong các
cái giá trị target nó được chuyên. Ừ
đúng bạn Thịnh này nó nói một ý đúng bạn
bạn Thịnh phải nói một ý đúng tức là gì?
Rest nó chỉ có khả năng nó trả về những
cái giá trị trong cái khoảng nó đã từng
được nhìn thấy đúng không? Tất nhiên là
với bài toán regression thì không bao
giờ chúng ta có thể kỳ vọng nó nó có thể
nhìn thấy tất cả giá trị được đúng
không? Ví dụ giá nhà từ 100 triệu đến 5
tỷ làm gì có chuyện là có có cái bộ rượu
nào nó cover hết được. Nó chỉ có một vài
giá trị trong khoảng đấy thôi đúng không
nào? Ai thấy được này.
Được
các bạn bấm vào ý của của bạn Thịnh đi.
Bạn Thịnh phải nói cái hin rất là quan
trọng đấy. Bạn đấy nói là bạn Thịnh nói
là Red nó chỉ trả được ra kết quả trong
các cái giá trị target nó được chuyên
thì không không đúng lắm. Tức là không
phải đúng những cái giá trị đấy mà trong
cái khoảng giá trị đấy đúng không? Giống
kiểu xây dựng mô hình dự án giá nhà ấy
nó cũng thế đúng không các bạn? Không
thể nào các bạn có một cái bộ rượu mà
cover hết các cái lại giá đâu. Nó chỉ
cover một phần thôi đúng không? Nhưng ý
của bạn Thịnh là có ý đúng không đấy?
Các bạn nhìn này, về mặt bản chất thì mô
hình forest được tạo ra bởi rất nhiều
cái decision tree đúng không? Decision
tre thì với bài toán classification thì
không nói làm gì. Còn bài toán rewestion
thì cái decion tre có cái đặc điểm gì là
nó chỉ có khả năng nó đưa ra những cái
dự đoán là những cái giá trị trong cái
khoảng lớn nhất và bé nhất nó đã từ được
nhìn thấy. Tức là gì? Trong bộ dữ liệu
huấn luyện cái target bé nhất là 100,
tait lớn nhất là 1000 chẳng hạn thì cái
mô hình Dentry được huấn luyện chên bộ
ấy nó cũng chỉ có khả năng dự đoán giá
trị trong khoảng từ 100 đến 1000 thôi.
Nó không vượt ra khỏi khoảng đấy được
đúng không? Mà Ron Fred thì về mặt bản
chất nó được tạo ra từ rất nhiều cái
decision tre thì bây giờ mỗi một ông chỉ
có thể dự án trong khoảng từ minim thì
đem ra thực tế nó cũng chỉ được như vậy
thôi. Thì các bạn thấy vẻ đúng không?
Rom chúng ta lúc chúng ta huấn luyện nó
chỉ nhìn thấy cái giá trị target là từ 3
mười mấy đến 360 cây kim thôi. Thế nên
là nó cũng chỉ có khả năng nó dự ấn
trong cái khoảng này thôi. Nó không vượt
quá cái khoảng này được. Đây 35 nă mấy
là là cái kim ví dụ như vậy đúng không?
Nó chỉ làm được đến như vậy thôi. Nó chỉ
có thể đưa dự đoán maximum là đến từng
này nên là muốn vượt quá thì không được.
Nên các bạn thấy đây nó chỉ bằng bằng
tại vì nó nó không vượt qua được đúng
không?
Thế vì sao linear reaction lại không bị
th này? Vì sao linear regression lại
không bị cái vấn đề này?
Vì sao?
Vì sao linear re lại không bị?
Không phải vì nó làm hàm thiệt tính.
Không phải. Không phải nó không phải vì
nó làm thế tính tại vì nó tại vì nó là
nó là một cái đường thẳng đúng không? Nó
cái đường thẳng nó đâu bị giới hạn đâu
đúng không? Trong quá trình huấn luyện.
Trong quá trình huấn luyện đi
đúng không? Trong quá trình huấn luyện
các bạn nhìn này đúng không? Các bạn vẽ
cái đường như này đúng không? Cho như hu
lệ các bạn chỉ cho nó nhìn thấy từ x đến
đây đến đây thôi nhưng mà nó vẫn có h nó
có thể dự những giá trị ở đây được ở đây
được đúng không nó không bị giới hạn
đúng không quá trình huấn luyện nó chỉ
nhn chỗ này chả cần sao cả đúng không y
= a + b nó vẫn dự dư ra những cái giá
trị nhỏ hơn ông này nhỏ hơn ông min này
đ max thoải mái chả vấn đề đó
thế đúng không
phải vấn đề của mô hình mà do tính chất
của mô hình nó là như thế nếu mà cái bộ
rượu này cái cái mức độ tiến triển của
dữ nó nằm nó nằm ngang thì ok nhưng mà
nó lại tăng lên thế là nó bị như này
được chưa? Mặc dù bài trước thì không bị
bài cái bài về student nó lại không bị
được chưa?
Đấy thế thôi đúng không?
Có nào câu hỏi gì không?
Bộ này có dễ mấy cái bộ mình cho các bạn
nó sẽ khó hơn. Đây chúng ta có ba cái bộ
nhá. mình up lên trên Google Drive hết
rồi. Chúng ta có ba cái bộ như này. S
này chúng ta có ba cái bộ này. Một cái
bộ là về nhu cầu thuê xe. Một cái bộ là
về sử dụng điện, một cái bộ là về web
traffic. Được chưa? Nó sẽ có nhiều rượu
hơn. Được chưa? Thì các bạn bài toán
tương tự thôi. Nhưng mà ví dụ cái web
traffic thì nó giống như bộ CO2 này. Còn
hai cái bộ kia các bạn sẽ có nhiều thông
tin hơn. Các bạn sẽ phải quyết định xem
là thông tin nào cần, thông tin nào
không và các bạn xử lý hiệu như thế nào.
Được chưa? Cái này là về cái nhu cầu sử
dụng điện này. Cái này là nhu cầu thuê
xe đạp ở một cái chỗ nào đấy, một cái
tiệm nào đấy. Được chưa? Có ai có câu
hỏi gì không?
Nhá đây thì thế cũng chưa hết đâu. Vẫn
còn nữa. Vẫn còn nữa. Chúng ta vẫn còn
mấy cái. Đây chúng ta mới chỉ dự đoán
được một giá trị trong tương lai thôi.
Chúng ta còn phải dự đoán được nhiều hơn
đúng không các bạn? Về các bạn thử nghĩ
xem là bây giờ tôi muốn dự đoán 5 6 10
dương lai tôi làm thế nào được chưa dựa
vào những cái ch đang có
đâu các bạn phải gộp đây này nhiều cột
nhìn nó như này chứ đây này không hôm
qua mình vừa học rồi đây
nhiều cột nhá
đây này trường hợp ở dưới này phải gộp
vào chứ đúng không phải gộp vào đây này
trường hợp này này cái trên là cái rượu
CO2 cái dưới là một cái lượng khác ví dụ
là nhiệt độ ngoài chơi chẳng hạn ví dụ
như vậy gộp nó Nào được chưa?
Các bạn cũng có thể các bạn sẽ xử lý
theo cách nào mà các bạn thấy là nó phù
hợp nhá. Được chưa? Đấy một cách tiêu
chuẩn như này. Được chưa?
Rồi có ai có thắc mắc gì không?
Các bạn ơi, mình rất là xin lỗi các bạn
là hôm nay mình chỉ dậy được một tiếng
thôi. Thì hôm nay mình phải mình phải
bảo họp rồi. Mình phải vào họp nữ rồi.
Hôm nay chủ nhật nhưng mà mà cũng cũng
cũng cũng cũng cũng không không thoát
được. Buổi hôm nay mình không vắng được
thật. Các bạn cho mình các bạn lại cho
mình xin xin khất các bạn nhá. Tất cả
những cái buổi thiếu của mình đến cuối
mình bù cho các bạn hết đủ nhá. Được
không? Tất cả những buổi nào thiếu mỗi
hôm thiếu một tí một tí đến cuối mình bù
lại hết các bạn nhá. Đảm bảo là các bạn
sẽ không bị thiếu mất giờ nào nhá nhá.
Các bạn chịu khó này. Cho nên hôm nay
xin cho mình xin phép mình mình nghỉ
mình nghỉ sớm một buổi nhá. Tuần sau
chúng ta học bình thường. Tuần sau mình
hứa các bạn hai buổi bình thường nhá.
Hôm nay
chúng ta vẫn còn một cái phần nữa của
cái recurs này. Sau chúng ta sẽ có cái
phần là direct
forasting. Cái direct thì nó cũng na ná
như này thôi nhưng mà nó sẽ có một vài
cái sự khác biệt một chút đúng không? Và
chúng ta phải xem ra là bây giờ tôi muốn
dự đoán nhiều giá trị trong tương lai
thì tôi làm thế nào thế? Nó không khó
đâu. Đơn giản là làm cái vòng lặp thôi.
Nhưng mà thử về nghĩ xem thứ nhất. Các
bạn thử về nghĩ xem bây giờ tôi muốn dự
án nhiều thì trong tương lai tôi làm thế
nào là cái thứ nhất. Thứ hai là đây bây
gi có ba bộ dữ liệu như vậy mình up trên
drive rồi. Các bạn lấy bộ nào cũng được.
Cái bộ cuối thì nó giống cái bộ CO2 này.
Có lẽ là hai bộ đầu nó sẽ có nhiều cái
thứ cho các bạn hơn. Các bạn thử lấy một
bộ ra sử mô hình dự xem như thế nào.
Được chưa? Hai cái bộ kia mấy cái bộ kia
nó sẽ có cái pattern nó không giống th
này đâu. Mỗi bộ pattern một kiểu nó
không giống nào giống nào đâu. Mỗi bộ
các bạn sẽ phải xem là tôi xử lý nó như
thế nào nhá.
nha. Hôm nay cho cho mình xin phép nhá.
Trên thứ phép tuần này chị chúng ta chỉ
học có 3 tiếng thôi. Buổi cuối mình sẽ
bù cho các bạn đủ ra mu đủ 17 buổi mỗi
buổi 2 tiếng là 34 tiếng nhá. Rất mong
mọi người thông cảm nha. Mình sẽ up cho
các bạn thứ nhất là record sẽ up ngay và
mình sẽ up luôn cho các bạn cái cái cái
script buổi hôm nay nữa nhá. Nhưng mà
như mình nói các bạn có làm không sao
các bạn vậy các bạn tự code lại theo cái
ý hiểu mình nó là quản nhất. Script mình
chỉ dùng để tham chiếu thôi nhá. Tham
khảo thôi nhá
nhá. Chúc các bạn tối nhật vui vẻ.
Chúc các bạn tuần mới học tập và làm
việc hiệu quả nhá. Tuần sau chúng ta lại
học bình thường các bạn nhá.
Bye mọi người nha. Bye mọi người nha.
Mọi người nha. Tuần sau sẽ học bình
thường nh. Tuần sau học bình thường nhá.